markus söder hat ja ausgesprochen dass
die produktionskapazität erhöht werden
müsste und dem ist nur zuzustimmen
man muss allerdings sagen herr uns aber
dass natürlich die unternehmen bei
montech selbst ein eigeninteresse haben
möglichst viel zu produzieren
denn es werden wettbewerber auf den
markt kommen dann ist der vorteil von
biontech irgendwann weg es heißt wir
wollen natürlich jetzt sehr viele
produkte politiker auch tun wenn man zum
beispiel seien hier in der produktion
und dennoch ich würde jetzt nicht
kriegsproduktion sagen wir sagen von es
ist ein krisenhafter zustand aber auch
wir eine krisen produktion und da ist
natürlich denkbar dass ein impfstoff
auch von anderen herstellern in lizenz
produziert wird nun ist dieser impfstoff
an sehr kompliziertes verfahren ist also
nicht einfach aspirin das irgendwo in
lizenz produziert wird das ist
voraussetzung voll aber wir sollten alle
voraussetzungen rechtlich wirtschaftlich
politisch technologisch treffen damit
schneller in diesem jahr geimpft werden
kann
das ist eine frage wie sie zurecht sagen
von leben und tod ist eine frage unserer
freiheit und es ist eine überlebensfrage
auch für unsere wirtschaft denn die es
schon auf der internetseite kann